rendez vous quotidien avec dr karl weiss
président de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
dr weiss bonsoir je veux vous parler
d'abord de l'allemagne parce que la
courbe du québec et du canada monsieur
legault a bien dit aujourd'hui le taux
de mortalité bien inférieure ici par
rapport à l'italie par exemple
mais l'élève modèle dans la préparation
de cette crise aidant les tests en grand
nombre c'est l'allemagne n'est ce pas
pour beaucoup de raisons d'abord pour
des raisons culturelles vous savez les
allemands sont des gens disciplinés et
organisés
donc quand on leur a dit de se confiner
de faire des choses particulières ils le
font de façon très ordonnée très
structurés ils suivent les conseils
le deuxième point c'est que l'allemagne
est un tissu industriel très important
notamment en chimie et dans les
industries mécaniques et dès le début de
la crise lorsque on savait que ça allait
arriver le gouvernement allemand a
demandé aux industriels allemands de se
préparer pour être capable de faire des
tests mais vous avez peut-être vu aussi
que la chancelière allemande angela
merkel a demandé au patron de fox star
game de bmv des deux mercedes de
commencer à fabriquer des ventilateurs
et donc de faire un consortium immédiat
pour faire ce genre de choses cela
par ailleurs le système allemand depuis
l'hospitalisation est un système où le
nombre de nids par habitant est beaucoup
plus élevé qu'au canada
donc par rapport à tout ça ils ont été
capables dès le début de commencer à
tester de façon importante d'isoler les
gens de d'essayer de contenir la vague
est un ensemble de facteurs ont fait que
la situation n'est pas rose non pli en
allemagne mais c'est sûr que si vous
comparez à la situation italienne ou
espagnole où c'est vraiment désastreux x
et il ya d'autres acteurs aussi qu'il
faut pas oublier parce que les hôpitaux
qui ont été frappés en espagne en italie
sont quand même des hôpitaux de classe
mondiale mais je ne dirai que tout ça
mis ensemble a fait que l'allemagne s'en
est beaucoup mieux tiré que ses voisins
européens
quand on se posait les gens se posaient
la question à ce qu'il y avait un pays
quelques pays sur la planète qui avait
pris davantage au sérieux la menace
d'une pandémie
la réponse l'allemagne dans la courte
laisse là oui tout à fait il ya quelques
pays qui ont réussi à faire cet aspect
là de façon je vous dirais beaucoup plus
structurée bon il ya l'allemagne est
singapour la corée ont possiblement à
son début il ya quelques autres pays qui
font six pas si mal
l'australie israël mais je vous dirais
pratico pratique le québec honnêtement
il faut pas qu'on se lance trop de
tomates
quand on se compare aux autres ont fait
relativement bien au québec
si on regarde le taux d'hospitalisation
si on regarde le taux de mortalité au
québec
et si on regarde le nombre de tests
qu'ont fait par jour au québec on a
quand même réussi à certainement se
placer parmi ce qui se fait de mieux sur
la planète peut être pas le mieux
on a des choses à apprendre il ya des
choses à améliorer on n'a pas la
capacité que l'allemagne a au niveau
industriel c'est clair mais il ya des
choses qui ont quand même été aussi bien
fait au québec très bien oui parce que
quand on compare le taux de mortalité le
québec effectivement vous avez raison de
souligner on le disait plus long savoir
relativement bien là un monstre mort de
trouille mais je pense que ce qu'il faut
aussi regarder ce sont les tendances il
faut faire très attention à essayer de
tirer des conclusions quotidienne sur
des chiffres parce que vous avez vu une
journée c'est pas bon une journée c'est
bonne journée c'est pas bon donc on peut
pas se mettre à tirer des conclusions en
disant mon dieu c'est en train de
déraper
je pense qu'il faut tirer des
conclusions sur de plus longues périodes
de temps etc sont des périodes ils sont
plutôt hebdomadaire que quotidienne il y
en aura une tendance de où s'en va
lutter bec et sur combien de semaines
tout ça va durer très bien alors on va y
aller rapidement et notre collègue
isabelle richer bon là ça lui nous avons
une question puisque le propre de la
personne asymptomatique et de ne pas
ressentir de symptômes
impossible de savoir quand commencer
quand fini la période de 14 jours
quand cesserons-nous d'être en danger un
danger pour nos proches c'est la
quadrature du cercle dit elle tout à
fait alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
quand vous êtes malade c'est facile tant
que vous avez des symptômes vous êtes
considéré comme étant infectieux donc
on va considérer que ça va durer 14
jours mais parfois plus longtemps mais
en cours pour l'être pour les fins
pratiques on va considérer 14 jours ce
qu'on fait de plus en plus les gens qui
commencent à se sortir complètement de
leurs symptômes surtout les gens les
plus malades ce qu'on a hospitalisé
on peut les tester pour voir s'ils sont
devenus négatifs on le sait aussi
tranquillement avec les travailleurs de
la santé pour savoir si on peut lire
faire venir travailler les gens
symptomatique c'est plus compliqué parce
que ces gens là évidemment par
définition ils ont pas de symptômes
donc vous avez aucune raison de penser
qu'ils peuvent transmettre la maladie et
c'est probablement eux qui jouent un
rôle important dans la dissémination du
virus puisque ce sont des gens qui se
promène un peu partout qui sont pas
malades donc ils vont vaquer à leurs
activités quotidiennes voilà à ce moment
là vont continuer c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que la courbe allemande a l'air moins
pire que les autres c'est que eux dès
qu'ils avaient un cas positif il teste
tout le monde autour comme ils ont fait
aussi à singapour immédiatement ils
mettent ces gens quarantaine de troupes
et justement les gens qui seraient
asymptomatiques mais positif très bien
alors on va aller rapidement je vous
posais deux autres questions que ça va
être terminé
la question 3 8511 personnes sont
décédées au canada de la grippe en 2018
pourquoi considère-t-on la coved 19 plus
grave c'est pour faire une réponse
courte c'est pas vrai que 8500 personnes
sont décédées c'est ce qu'on pense
qu'ils sont décédés souvent quelques
kills en faisant des calculs
statistiques d'excès de mortalité dans
certains mois par rapport à d'autres et
on attribue sa halle influence donc le
ont offert un jour un débat complet sur
la mortalité attribué à l'influenza
mais on n'est pas dans la même ligue 1
quand on compare fin la police 19
donc la mortalité le même si on ne s'est
pas définitif le taux de mortalité de la
coved 19
elle est plus élevée que la grippe
soucier sans contredit tout le monde le
dit et il ya les fauchés de dix ans
j'avais j'avais dit aux enfants nous
écrire je veux prendre le temps de si je
joue avec mes voisins dehors ça commence
mal que je garde deux mètres de distance
avec eux bon que je porte un masque en
tissu et que je lave mes mais en
rentrant
est-ce que je peux jouer avec eux sans
risque de contamination alors sans
risque de contamination non je pense que
c'est déjà
bien de prendre le lavage des mains
d'essayer de garder une distance
d'essayer à la limite de se protège en
mettant un masque artisanale mais c'est
sur faut éviter ça au maximum
je pense que les gens peuvent se parler
à distance surtout avec les enfants il
faut pas oublier qu'ils sont peu malade
souvent asymptomatique
donc ils peuvent transmettre de microbes
à d'autres sans s'en rendre compte
alors on sait que les enfants sont
beaucoup moins malades que les eaux très
bien alors d'un monde n'allait pas jouer
dehors avec vos amis parce que deux
mètres on pense qu'on l'appuie ont loupé
et un ballon qui tombe on va chercher up
me suis rapproché
c'est peut-être ne pas jouer dr weiss on
se reparle ans je viens vous garder plus
de ta demain promis merci d'être là tous
les soirs
bonne soirée à voir